merci madame ministre la parole est à
monsieur julien aubert mais monsieur le
premier ministre je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur la réforme du régime
social des indépendants comme vous le
savez depuis plusieurs mois l'opposition
les républicains mais également lui d y
travaillent sur ce sujet qui concerne
des dizaines de milliers d' indépendants
dans notre pays qui sont par ailleurs
écrasée de charge mais qui se plaignent
de ce régime qu'il voit comme une
forteresse sans fenêtre s'emporte
brutale des recours massif aux huissiers
et également un conséquent dans le
calcul des cotisations
voilà pourquoi après plusieurs mois de
travail bruno le maire et moi même ainsi
que 150 parlementaires ont décidé de
rendre des propositions de soumettre des
propositions au débat public
j'en profite pour vous dire que nous
regrettons de ne pas avoir été associée
à la mission que vous avez nommés
mission qui a abouti également il ya
quelques semaines ses propositions il
s'agirait de limiter le recours aux
huissiers devenue quasi systématique de
créer un fonds d'indemnisation des
cotisants notamment pour les naufragés
du rsi en regardant la responsabilité
des acteurs publics dans ce qui est
convenu d'appeler une catastrophe
industrielle de permettre la liberté
d'affiliation sans modification du
statut juridique pour ces indépendances
qui leur permettrait d'aller notamment
au régime général de leur permettre
d'auto liquidés et d'auto déclarer leurs
cotisations et contributions sociales de
manière à ce que la charge de la preuve
appartiennent au rsi et non pas aux
déclarants lorsqu'il y a un différentiel
sur la cotisation d'étaler le règlement
de ses cotisations de droit sur 36 mois
de manière à lisser l'activité
économique et enfin le premier ministre
de créer un bouclier social pour les
indépendants c'est à dire que le rsi ne
pourraient pas venir prélevées au delà
d'un certain plafond de manière
respecter le travail et de donner un
reste à vivre
monsieur le premier ministre c'est une
question importante il y a des milliers
d' indépendants qui attend de votre
réponse
il est peut-être temps de faire l'union
sacrée sur ce
g et enfin de faire avancer ce dossier
merci monsieur robert la parole est à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés pu seul
député aubert merci d'inviter les
primaires de l'est républicain ici au
sein de l'hémicycle
mais cette question où vous appelez
l'unité nationale mérite toujours un
petit rappel historique pour connaître
la responsabilité d'un régime que la
cour des comptes a calais a qualifié de
catastrophe industrielle je cite c'est
la majorité de l'époque qui a créé ce
dispositif dans la précipitation que
tous les acteurs avaient annoncé pour
autant monsieur le député vous avez
raison il faut résoudre les problèmes
parce qu'il en subsiste le rapport
fabrice verdier sylviane bulteau a posé
un certain nombre de propositions
il a été reçu par le premier ministre
mais sans attendre ce rapport nous avons
mis en place un certain nombre de
dispositions notamment pardon de rentrée
de la technique mais c'est important le
fait que les cotisations sont dorénavant
calculée sur l'année n - 1
elle l'était sur l'année n - 2 ce qui
provoquait des décalages qui pénalisait
l'activité de cotisants pour autant il
faut aller plus loin avec les acteurs
avec marisol touraine
les ministres concernés martine pinville
nous avons rencontré les acteurs qui
gère le régime social des indépendants
en matière de médiation des éléments été
mis en place pour éviter ce que vous
avez
exposés et qui est une réalité
l'utilisation parfois précipités et
abusive d'un certain nombre de moyens de
recouvrement il faut laisser un peu de
temps pour que ce régime
encore une fois mis en place dans la
précipitation trouve son équilibre en
matière de fonctionnement
même si l' équilibre financier est
encore loin d'être atteint puisque les
prestations des indépendants sont les
mêmes que celles du régime général et
tout rattachement régime général
provoquerait l'augmentation des
cotisations
merci monsieur min